on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
we're gonna sensor back with a bang and
two big exclusives that he calm says his
climate change cameras will clear the
air because they cost his party the
general election the mayor of London
makes his long-awaited uncensored debut
thus is the breakout star of the U.S
presidential race Vivek ramaswamy is
surging in popularity but how do you
beat Trump by being Trump's biggest
cheerleader he'll join me hopefully to
explain
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
well good evening from London and
welcome to Piers Morgan and says it is
good to be back but nothing saps the
national libido more than the noxious
sense that nothing is working most of us
imagine that countries Fall Apart in
violent shocks like a stock market
collapse or a military coup the reality
is that it's much slower and even more
depressing it's a creeping Insidious
odor of decline which lurks at the back
of the nostrils and eventually
overwhelms the senses and in Britain
right now the putrid stench of failure
is everywhere children return to school
today but thousands won't be because
dangerous cheap concrete ignored for
years as their school buildings in
danger of collapse instead of fronting
up on interviews on how she'd handle
this massive crisis the education
secretary did this black stands for
reinforced autoclaved aerated concrete
and it's a lightweight form of concrete
that was used in building construction
from the 1950s until the mid 1990s
problems with the strength and
durability of the material mean that
some buildings May pose a threat to
safety and nothing is more important
than the health and safety of children
and staff the industry's understanding
of the risks of right has evolved over
time if you ever watched anything more
patronizing than that what are we
five-year-olds what was she thinking the
education system is quite literally
collapsing and the education the
secretary uploads of video looks like a
health and safety training manual from
1995.
well this morning we finally decided
you're to answer some questions Keegan
summer managed to make it worse it is
not the job of the Department of
Education but we chose to do that
because we wanted to make sure that we
had that information centrally on top of
that yeah but you're saying that the
government is not responsible ultimately
for the safety of children in school the
the school building's responsibility is
with local authorities and multi-academy
do you believe the government did
everything but we've taken further now
let me get me straight sorry so the
education
Secretary of this country in our
government is not responsible for
schools literally falling to pieces
well this job is here then whose
responsibility is that
with their reputation appropriately
disintegrating faster than some of these
schools she was then caught on a hot mic
saying this
thank you
does anyone ever say you know what
you've done a good job because everyone
else has sat on there and done nothing
no no signs of that no
well no with respect Mrs Keegan well say
you've done an effing good job when
you've got off your backside and
actually sorted this mess out
crumbling buildings of a perfect
metaphor for how most people feel about
the country right now sadly for the
government it's not the schools One
hospital made from the same shoddy
concrete says it can only treat fat
patients on the ground floor in case
they fall through the floors above
sounds like a comedy sketch but it's
real this is happening in Britain in
it feels like a country with neglected
failing infrastructure where National
paralysis lurks around every corner it
doesn't get a quarter of a million
people face travel chaos when the air
traffic control system was brought to
its knees by one single misfile flight
plan all the seven and a half million
people are stuck on the NHS waiting
lists seeing a GP as I asking for an
audience with a pope it rained most of
the summer but there's hose pipe bands
in several places because our rotten
water companies almost literally failed
to fix the roof when the Sun was shining
our biggest supermarket chain there's a
strapping body cameras on his workers
because they're so worried about the
rise in violent attacks on staff
mortgages are rocketing everyone's on
strike inflation is draining our wallets
as toxic sewage drips into our seas and
you're more likely to strike oil than
find a dentist against this backdrop
there's been the worrying rise in
Vigilantes they've stepped in where
police won't to shift Eco protesters off
our roads and they've taken to now run
clean air cameras in London which now
Bill motor is 12 pounds 50 a day but
driving a Mercedes in all the cars
now in my view this kind of behavior is
as wrong as the Eco Warriors who go
around spraying paint everyone and
everything
though of a sick country where people
think that nothing works including the
police and they're tired of it so
they're getting on with action
themselves prime minister Rishi Suna
took on a hospital pass to the job no
question he has steadied the ship to a
certain degree but it'll take a lot more
energy and more bold risk-taking if
we're going to dodge the iceberg the
government thinks that eat Khan's air
pollution cameras are so vastly
unpopular they could help swing next
year's election back in his favor but
the only air quality they should be
worrying about honestly is the stench of
national decline
well shortly before I came on air
tonight I spoke to the man of the moment
the mayor of London City calm well I'm
delighted to say I'm joined now by the
mayor of London City Khan Mr Mayor good
to see you
it's been too long because I'm just only
sorry we're not doing this in person but
it's lovely to be with you again
although the first time in your on your
new show or it's not you anymore is it
well it's not new and you have resisted
my advances for quite some time so
what's made you finally succumb
well I think to be fair we were trying
to hook something up a few weeks ago but
you were very busy doing stuff uh
overseas and I'm just really sorry it's
taken so long hopefully next time I'll
be in person well
uh we've always I think had a robust
exchange of views over the years let's
start with the obvious subject which is
your campaign about air quality in
London I want to preface this part of
the interview by saying that I have gone
through a quite uh well interesting
journey I think about pollution in
London so I thought I had a big issue
with hay fever for quite a few years and
eventually had a lot of tests done
revealed no allergies at all and then
had a local chemist who said to me I
think it may be pollution is it worse
when you come back from overseas I went
actually yes it is and it was knocking
me out for like half a day every week
and he recommended getting some air
purifiers and getting an air quality app
and not going out too much when it was
very high I did both those things I've
got four purifiers in my house now 80
pounds each and it's completely
transformed my health I'm a different
human being in the last eight months to
what I'd been like in the previous few
years I then did some digging into the
borough I live in Kensington and Chelsea
and discovered to my horror that is one
of the worst places in the country for
air pollution and that there's a lot of
people who die from pollution related
deaths in Kensington and Chelsea so I'm
I'm a convert to your cause I I believe
it is a real issue I've been through an
experience myself that's made me see the
benefit of having better quality air
albeit through uh purifiers but here's
the problem that I think you've
encountered it's a similar problem to
the just stop oil protests
where I agree with their calls but I
don't agree with the methodology and it
seems to me that your ulez scheme
albeit well-intentioned and I think we
all want to get to where you want to get
to an air quality but it's turned out to
be incredibly divisive you know this
very polarizing the polls actually show
us pretty split down the middle about
what people's views are perhaps if you
live in the outer part of London more
extremely against it than those who live
in the inner part of the of the city but
it is very divisive and it is very
controversial do you have any regrets
about the methodology
foreign thank you for the thoughtful way
you've asked the question because I like
you were on a journey in 2014 uh 2015 I
had no idea uh about what you've
discovered either I was feeling out of
breath when I was playing football I was
getting tired very quickly I had some
really bad days where I was wheezing and
coughing and I'm like you reasonably
well informed I think I know a bit about
uh you know things like air pollution
air quality climate change but I have no
idea that this invisible thing we can't
see particularly matter and nitrogen
dark side is making us sick and so the
evidence in relation to the consequences
of air pollution uh you and I live in
out but also in our city around 4 000
people die prematurely because of air
pollution across our country according
to government figures not mine
government figures
between twenty eight thousand and thirty
six thousand and at least the children
having stunted lungs forever and adults
like you and I with a whole host of
health issues from asthma to cancer
dementia to heart disease but also
appears to answer your question directly
I've seen the evidence of the Euless in
central London where it exists and in
Illinois where it exists and I'll tell
you what I mean by that so we introduced
the Euros in central London and So
within a year an almost 50 reduction in
toxicity but also a third fewer children
with air pollution alleged illnesses
being rushed to hospital uh a third
reduction we expanded it to Inner London
and we saw a further 20 reduction in air
pollution and children going to 1400
schools were breathing cleaner air let
me see the problem it's in outer London
that's the worst air the 10 boroughs
with the largest amount of premature
deaths are in outer London uh what we've
also seen is that 24 of the 30 GPS with
the worst number of patients is an
outline so that's the aim but what I've
tried to also appears is to listen to
the genuine concerns and I recognize by
the way peers in relation to regret over
a number of years in outer London we
haven't got the good quality public
transport we've got in central London
and in London so more people are relying
on cars in outer London the good use uh
9 out of 10 cars now driving in outer
London are already compliant won't pay a
penny more but we'll see the benefits of
cleaning okay
I don't I don't want to get into arguing
about the merits of what you're trying
to do because I actually broadly agree
with you on the methodology it seems to
me here's your problem in a nutshell I
have an Aston Martin right a very
luxurious car I'm very lucky to have
lucky to earn enough money to be able to
keep it up and you don't charge me a
penny to drive that around London as
much as I like because I'm always
compatible but if I lived in North
London in Wembley or somewhere and I was
a hard-working guy woman and you're
driving a van maybe for work and you
have to come into town every day and
you're already facing massive cost of
living uh extra costs for your family
you're struggling to feed your family
you're really feeling the pinch and now
suddenly you who really can't afford
just to get through the day as it is are
suddenly having to pay another 12 pounds
50 every day to you why am I being
spared just because I can afford to have
a more expensive u-less compatible car
and why are a large number of people who
are having to pay actually at the poorer
end of the spectrum of London society
that is where your Optics I think are
failing
so because your car is US compliant it
means that you're off Euro full or
better what that means appears is when
you drive your car at your wife maybe
next to your daughter in the back
they're not breathing in Poison the same
way somebody driving a non-compliant car
is that's the first point the second
point is what we're doing is to support
the hard-working van driver you talked
about to support the low income family
you're talking about to support the
charity within minibus you may be
talking about we're giving financial
support to the tune of 160 million
pounds so a small van owner a small
business with a van like yours will now
receive uh support uh seven thousand
Pounds to get a ulyss compliant value
you may be right in your cause I believe
you're right about trying to get better
air quality but you know that the labor
party are very concerned about it I want
to play you a little mashup of what
labor figures have been saying about it
I don't think there's any doubt that us
was the reason that we lost the
by-election in Uxbridge and I have said
we should reflect on this include I've
spoken to him as you would expect and so
there will be that reflection the cost
is a problem and if you look at who pays
you less it tends to be poorer families
and smaller businesses I'm afraid that
the hard truth is
at 12 pounds an hour or sorry 12 pounds
a day fee costs labor that by-election
there is a massive cost of living crisis
at the moment and and asking people to
Shell out thousands to buy a new vehicle
or pay 12.50 every day to to go on the
road is is is just a an expense to too
many now these aren't Tories saying this
this is your own side they think that
this is an election liability how would
you feel if you go down this path you
dig your heels in as you're doing you
keep going but it ends up potentially
becoming an election deciding issue in
the next year or so whenever that
general election may come that the
Tories use this as a weapon to actually
defeat you you very generously and
rightly said that in central London uh
people support euros and in inner London
but there's some concern in outer London
I would argue the reason why people in
central London and Inland and support
policies because they've seen it bedded
in and they realize it's not as bad as
they said it was going to be I I'll give
you some breaking news when I announced
the central London policy people were
against that as well initially until we
had a scrappage scheme and they saw the
benefits were far better than the
disbenefits why if the government has
helped out other cities up and down the
country why have they not helped you out
well I think I think this goes to the
core of the anger you're talking about
which is basically the government that
thinks because of Uxbridge and ruislip
they're actually tackling climate change
entitling air pollution uh are vote
losers and so they've weaponized this as
an issue I likely in view of the pretty
extreme reaction from half of your
people in London are you likely to
evolve this policy and reflect their
concerns yeah we will always listen to
londoners the first week of August I
said every single person in London it
doesn't matter how much you earn uh you
will get support in relation to the
scrap rescue and the reason why they
that's not giving London support they're
given Birmingham support and Bristol
support and bath support is they think
by attacking londoners they may do
better at the general election so
londoners are pawns caught in this
Crossfire nobody wins if people are
dying prematurely nobody wins if kids
have stunted lungs true but nobody wins
if half of the people in London hate you
because they think you're targeting the
poorer members of society over people
like me I've got to be
I've got to be frank peers you asked the
question at the top of the this
interview which is which was you know
why am I on this show I got to be honest
one of the reasons I'm on this show is
because I recognize me and my voters you
know watch this show and I'm Keen to
talk to them through you peers you ask
me the tough questions that they that
they ask me and I respond to uh as well
because I genuinely think those people
see the benefits of this policy they'll
come with me listen like I said at the
start I I'm with you about the the
problem of air pollution I've seen it
myself I've seen it to my own health so
I'm with you on that but let's move on
to some other stuff in the news today
Jillian Keegan the education secretary
who many people are very angry with
because of this crisis over schools
being closed because of the concrete
that have been used to build them and
we're blaming the government for not
acting sooner she responded like this
off mic in an interview today today with
ITV
thank you
does anyone ever say you know what
you've done a good job because everyone
else has sat on there and done nothing
no no signs of that no
do you feel this is a good moment Mr
Mayor to tell the educational secretary
she's done an effing good job I I've not
seen that until just now
um
look I mean
I mean for those that don't know we had
a conversation before we went on air
that's you know so there's you can be
caught out with you know hot mic as they
call it but I think the problem the
problem is
uh I mean the arrogance in relation to
you know thinking you should be going to
pat on the back I I spent Friday
speaking to really worried parents who
didn't know
whether their kids are going to school
on Monday whether they're to organize
child care my sister's a teacher as is
my sister-in-law they had no idea
whether their schools are affected I was
also an MP in 2010 lobbying Michael Gove
and the government saying for goodness
sake please don't cut the program you're
going to cut the building schools the
future program that had balls had
announced and you know austerity has
consequences and I think Julian Keegan
needs to understand children are caught
in the crossfire because of government
cuts for the last 13 years and rather
than asking for a pat on the back
she needs to be spoken working night and
day to make our schools safe and it you
know it is a problem
the fact that literally I think our
Public Services crumbling literally our
schools are crumbling yeah I completely
agree I thought it was unbelievably
arrogant and tone deaf uh let's talk
about women because she's a woman
what is a woman Mr Mayor
well I asked that question known full
well that people have been watching this
who may have gender dysphoria and may
you know have concerns in relation to
this issue it's going to be quite Direct
in relation to this so a woman when it
comes to biology and sex is an adult
girl
but there are some women who may have
gender dysphoria and you know trans
women can also be women as well
Ron says the next city cars bet a few
with Donald Trump has rage for years and
what happens next will be nothing to
improve the chances of any peace deal
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to piersburg Grand Central
League Khan's long and fiery few with
former president Donald Trump we've made
the London mayor a big name across the
pond he does nothing to dance those
Flames I'm a second part of our
interview
at City Hall you have a weird series of
rules have been laid down you don't like
gender specific phrases like ladies and
gentlemen to be used because it may
exclude non-binary people what if what
if somebody wants to be called a lady or
a gentleman you know British Airways
have done this too and I'm like hang on
when I get on a plane I actually quite
like to be called a gentleman where are
my rights to still be called a gentleman
well I'm not sure about that oh well
about that being City Hall rule what I
can tell you about myself categorization
okay
I I love days when I call a gentleman uh
you know but I think what may what it
may be is you know somebody may have
said friends or people or londoners I
don't know but no nothing is banned you
know well it's an advisory it says for
example migrants shouldn't be called
illegal even if they're illegal migrants
they should be called insecure
immigration status people or
undocumented but frankly if that's
illegal I can deal with that even if
they're an illegal mind or a legal
migrant why do you care what what the
phraseology is
let me do that so when you're an asylum
Seeker come into the UK there are there
are no safe routes to come to the UK and
what the government has done is outlawed
medic criminal offense to come to the UK
as for Asylum Seekers so many Asylum
Seekers who come to the UK may be
defined as illegal migrants because of
the government passing this law which is
isn't law in other countries but they
are asylums because you go on
to become refugees many of them great
britons cover the quick ones before I
let you go my father front runner in the
Republican race remains Donald Trump you
and he have got a pretty checked history
to put it mildly you've allowed a big
balloon of him as a baby to fly over
Westminster when he came into town he's
been pretty scathing about you how would
you feel if he is re-elected president
of the United States
just to get full context I also allowed
a balloon of me with a bikini to fly in
London
it could have been what it could have
been me in person with a bikini what
sauce with a goose but can I say this is
my problem with Trump I've got a number
of problems with with President Trump
and and you know I've discussed this in
the past is
how I felt how I felt
uh when he says some of the things about
the religion that I follow how my family
felt in America proud Americans proud
Muslims about what he said about women I
know how they felt when he was elected
but you'll have seen what happened on
Capitol Hill
uh you know when you know listen there's
losing with dignity being magnanimous in
uh defeat and what happened at Capitol
Hill for those who were agnostic or not
sure should be the final straw in
relation to his Fitness for uh office
this is this is America for goodness
sake you know you and I are big fans of
West Wing we look to America as a beacon
for democracy human rights separation of
powers uh you know so forth the checks
and balances and I think sometimes you
know yes challenge is good debate is
good but sometimes people are not fit
for office and I frankly don't think and
I don't want to cause offense to your
American views and stuff I do not think
Donald Trump is fit to be the president
of that great country I mean should
somebody who's facing nearly a hundred
criminal charges just on basic principle
should they be allowed to be a candidate
for president as the Constitution stands
at the moment he is allowed to be he
could be president and be in prison
can I say one of the wonderful things in
the joys of America is due process and I
think it's right that Donald Trump has
his day or days in court I think there
is a presumption of innocence uh there's
a separate discussion about whether
somebody who's Presumed Innocent should
be barred from Office you know I I think
as a form of human rights lawyer that
may be unfair you know you're charged
with an offense not found guilty a he
later may be acquitted I think there's a
separate discussion about uh about that
for argument's sake if Trump was
convicted of a criminal defense before
the election what would your position be
then
what will surely surely then you'd
expect the the the the uh you know
there'd be provision where he's not
allowed to start with a conviction
particularly if it's a conviction to do
with what happened on Capitol Hill
particularly if it's to do the
conviction in relation to a dishonesty
and so if there is to be a lawyer
appears if you've got even a manic
conviction for dishonesty the Law
Society doesn't allow you to be a lawyer
right because you're you're treating
you've got client money and so forth and
so forth you know and so I think you
know the president of the United States
is is not not arguably it probably is
definitely is the most powerful person
in uh the world the idea something with
a conviction can be leader of the
country Beggars believe but also let me
see the problem what message does that
send to people across the great country
of America and around the globe in
relation to no consequences for your
action final question Mr Mayor I know
you've been very generous with your time
but uh recent studies showed that there
have been more than 300
000 racist messages about you since you
became mayor in 2016 and that number's
increased exponentially since the
uh story has played out and you've said
that you've had PTSD from some of this
abuse This Racist abuse you've been
suffering we had the founder of Pimlico
plumbers Charlie Mullins banned from
Twitter now called X after writing
racist and threatening comments about
you referencing the fact you're a Muslim
mayor and saying that you should be you
should be killed someone should kill him
how did you feel when you read that from
such a high profile person
I I want to say Beggar's belief
um nothing surprises me anymore
a small the impact of my daughters you
know you you you're on the receiving end
of of some of this stuff as well and so
and you know as a dad you worry about
your kids right or you know I don't know
how they are and as my daughter's seen
that that upset me the most
um you know my wife's an adult you know
she's you know she's you know she's seen
some of the stuff but but also when you
say this stuff even though you might say
you don't mean it how do you know how
somebody else is going to react to it in
relation to you know the phenomenon of
grooming being radicalized incitement
and so listen I'm up for robust debate I
think it's really important in democracy
people should be acting in a way that
make their views clear but it should be
lawful peaceful and safe and that's one
of the reasons by the way I'm like you I
support you know the ends in relation to
just oil and existing Rebellion I don't
I don't support some of their tactics
because they're not lawful safe and
peaceful but this goes on the other side
of that because your inciting others
to not just commit criminal offense
but to kill me I mean you know I was
somebody who was close friends with you
know Joe Cox who was murdered in 2016 I
mean you know we were close and so and
you've you know from the work you do
people across the globe who are often
the receiving end when people act on
these sorts of message and listen you've
challenged me during this interview and
and you will confirm nothing was off
balance in relation to the challenge
that's the joy of a democracy yeah I
agree but in inciting people inciting
people to create criminal offenses can
make criminal damage I think come on I
mean you know save somebody did behave
in a way
that you know uh brings to life uh what
people like that are saying and I'm at
the receiving end or say you're creating
an environment
where my ethnicity and my religion is a
relevant issue uh and I just think you
know we live in a a Multicultural
multi-racial Society
um the great thing about our country and
our city is there is no ceiling bomb
which you can't go through forget the
glass ceiling being smashed it was
decimated ages ago and you're just doing
back some of the progress making I just
I'd implore people yes be a critical of
me sign petitions go on demos you know
don't vote for me if you don't want to
vote for me and stuff but there's got to
be a line you know beyond magician
across no I completely agree with you
it's disgusting uh and to you know
Mullins has apologized since then he's
been taken off Twitter which is good
good to see Elon musk's uh Twitter X's
it now is uh taking action to take him
off for that because that's unacceptable
and I'm glad he has apologized for it um
just want to leave on a positive note Mr
Mayor you've just committed 135 million
pounds of funding meaning that 287 000
more State primary school children in
London will get free School meals from
this week that is a great thing to do
and I congratulate you on it
thanks physically I was somebody who had
the benefit of free School meals that's
great we've got a picture I think of you
and your brothers actually which uh you
put up okay all sweet I'm the good
looking I'm the I'm the good looking one
in the center
I'm sure that like my brothers they
might take issue with that but I think
it's great uh Mr Mayor it's good to have
you on Facebook and I said so don't
leave us alone next time I promise I
won't thank you for joining me
or you can watch the full uncut
interview with London's mayor's Elite
Khan on the Piers Morgan uncensored
YouTube channel which includes what this
uh lately in the interview he said about
Julian Keegan
there are some days when I see our prime
minister former I think he's not for the
job either
I mean some of the decisions he makes I
mean come on he should have such a lean
Keegan he showed me that video If I Was
sunac now and you showed me that video
of Jillian Keegan I'd be demanding she'd
be kicked out would you you know his
decision to yeah he was the chancellor
he was a chancellor who decided as
Chancellor to reject the advice of the
adjacent secretary and cut the school's
budget by a half that was going into
repairing the schools and spent half
that budget instead are an ideological
free schools uh project and so and those
chicks coming up to roost
interesting stuff will Rishi sunak fire
his education secretary well he probably
won't just because so the guy tells him
to but it was very intemporary of what
she said and our handling of this has
been frankly pretty appalling uncensored
next he's the breakout star of the U.S
presidential race but can be baked
Brahma Swami actually win maybe with me
next
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City yeah King peers and
King Cube I think there's only one for
one king
he's mocked your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin well don't mean they're
kinfolks you believe you can win this
war but he's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
will die behind bars and a senior Doctor
Who first raised concerns about that he
wants NHS managers to be regulated we
needed answers a lot sooner this is what
seven years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board should
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
foreign
[Music]
if we stop producing oil the knock-on
effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know I know you're probably going
to vote me off shorts
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American Air thank you
very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has Battalion
materials you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
[Music]
this is talk TV
Prime Minister President Trump Mr
President first lady Stormy Daniels
Jordan Peterson welcome to all these
people protesting just don't get it many
of them don't isn't that slightly
patronizing
when you're going through the treatments
you have some tears God I'm such a softy
I'm not a performing monkey come on
Brian and it's something that really
hurt me because they doubt of my words
a woman is me a woman is somebody whose
breasts hang down to her stomach I
thought the marginalized we're supposed
to have a voice I've been a terrible
liar
you're being a Karen pass Morgan
[Music]
condoms the kids caskets we'll get you
coming and we'll get you going I think
it's only room for one king man now I'm
saying
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook around says
there's some pretty good interviews
there so if you think we've been the
best interview show out there this year
though for us in the National Television
Awards you've got a few hours left
before we all trudge down there to the
O2 and hopefully don't have my miserable
unhappy face when I've got my pack
waiting to comment on that Sadiq con
interview but also to talk about my next
guest because the 2024 presidential race
so far it was like to be a rerun
potentially of Donald Trump against Joe
Biden but this weekend a grand swallow
commentators claimed that Trump could
yet be disqualified from the ballot
altogether over his alleged attempts to
inspire Insurrection my next guest may
have some pretty strong feelings about
that The Vape ramaswamy is the breakout
star of the Republican race so far the
only one frankly to rival Trump for any
kind of publicity or momentum there's
just one problem it doesn't really
explained yet how he'll actually beat
Trump or Vivek joins me now great to see
you again
it's good to see you pierce how are you
well first of all an apology because
I've always called you Vivek and then
you very kindly corrected us all and
said you are Vivek as in cake
that's correct I appreciate best efforts
but uh I usually save the air time for
substance but thank you I appreciate
look we've done a few interviews Vivek
so far and obviously when it started not
many people knew much about you other
than your entrepreneurial stuff now
since the last debate uh you've become
incredibly well known very well talked
about and a lot of uh unfriendly fire is
coming your way so my first question is
how are you handling being now in the
proper Spotlight of being a presidential
candidate
I'm fine with it and I do think Pierce
that's part of the process we jumped
into this race early on going in Eyes
Wide Open knowing that politics is a
dirty sport it's filled with falsehoods
you may have seen a report over the
weekend that actually one of the other
candidates large super Pacs was taking
credit to their donors for the donors
for the attacks that have been
manufactured against me that's okay I
can handle it and to tell you the truth
if I'm asking the people of this country
to ask me to represent the U.S across
the table from Xi Jinping I better be
able to sit across the table from other
candidates or from left-wing Media or
anybody else and so we're doing just
fine with it I'm focused on what we want
to achieve for this country shutting
down the administrative State keeping us
out of World War III declaring
independence from China growing the
economy Reviving national pride these
are my actual Focus areas not some side
attacks that could I really could care
less for okay you've certainly been so
far I would argue the most pro-trump of
the other candidates but that raises the
question if he's so great even to the
extent you were pardon him of any crimes
you make him be convicted of why would
you run against it why not just let
Donald Trump run again and potentially
win again and maybe you get a a good job
out of it otherwise if you keep talking
him up how does that help you
so the answer is I'm not looking at
what's going to help myself or not I'm
looking at speaking the truth and I do
think he was an excellent president as
judged by results but I'm going to
deliver something that he did not
National Unity uniting this country is a
top objective for me I'm 38 years old I
am the youngest person ever to run for
U.S president as a Republican and peers
we're reaching the Next Generation in
droves we're Reviving national pride
amongst Young Americans 40 percent of my
hundred thousand plus donors are first
time ever donors to the Republican party
in any form that is unheard of that
number is normally two percent and so
yes I'm 90 of policy areas I do agree
with Donald Trump and I respect his
accomplishments but there's more to a
president than just being a policy book
in a binder part of this is how we
reunite this nation I think I'll be best
positioned to accomplish that and I look
forward to working with Donald Trump
when I hope he's my advisor frankly my
mentor in my first year in office that
much I will take but that's how I think
this is going to play out you managed to
say that you thought Donald Trump would
be your advisor as president with a
straight face there Vivek
I do I think he's somebody who has a lot
of experience I don't want to start with
a standing start I want to build on
those four years of experience
just to explain on the agenda to the
next level no no I can see why you would
want him as an advisor since the idea of
trump playing second fiddle to anyone I
think he's highly unlikely uh and I
guess my overriding view is how do you
beat him he's so far ahead you know you
had a good debate I thought in many ways
you've got a lot of publicity out of it
but it hasn't really moved the needle on
the polls Trump is so far ahead he looks
Unstoppable and all these indictments
all they seem to be doing is helping him
well I'll tell you one thing I I'm dead
set against these indictments that is
not how I want to win this election
seeing the cop opposition eliminated no
that's the wrong way to do it in this
country I will say this though Pierce I
started people said you started at zero
percent in March I said nope I started
at 0.0 in March I'm now a solid second
or third in nearly every major national
poll that's coming out and many people
in this country didn't even know who I
was six months ago most people couldn't
pronounce my name until two weeks ago
and so the fact of the matter is we're
on our way up I'm still introducing
myself to the country and I'm confident
that we're going to be successful
talking to you let me ask you this from
a farm in New Hampshire we're meeting
voters and I think we're very confident
about where we're at you are going to
have to take the gloves off with Trump
at some stage maybe on a debate stage so
what what don't you like about Donald
Trump
well look it's less about what I don't
like about him but what I do think this
country needs to go further I will unite
this country and if Trump was going to
do that in his four years that would
have already happened he delivered great
results but I think we have to actually
speak about this country in a way that
reaches the Next Generation talk about
what it means to be an American these
two devices I'm not in this race to run
against anybody but I am unique
ways to be unified you and I think
that's I know I know that's the essence
of what's differences
you are in a race and you are going to
have to try and beat Donald Trump and
it's interesting
the dividing point of view is these two
divisive right
well I think I am more unifying that's
the answer and I think that that's more
important and the way we're going to
unite this country is not by tearing
down other people who have made great
contributions to this country Donald
Trump being high on that list among them
but by actually articulating what this
country stands for answer what it means
to be an American at a moment where
we're in the middle of a national
identity crisis fill that void in the
heart of the millennial generation and
younger with an actual vision of
national identity instead of woke poison
or any other poison that fills that void
that's how we win
something for a long time we gotta run
start running to something that's what
I'm doing there's a little stuff about
you I really like you know hey you come
on my show a lot which I love and you
you do a lot of interviews and you're up
front and you take the tough questions
you go in lots of places where you might
get a hard time I love the energy I love
the dynamism really us but there are
aspects of some of your policy stuff
which I really don't like one of which
is your position on Ukraine and I want
to you this is a tweet that you did on
the day the war started
Putin is a bully the way to stop a bully
is to punch him in the nose you said now
now your position is you should just
give unless I'm wrong you should Ukraine
should just give Putin the land he's
stolen with his illegal War I don't know
how you equate those two statements
so Pierce I think there's two things
here one is we should have never been in
this situation in the first place
because if the U.S actually had energy
Independence if we drilled we fracked we
were a net exporter of energy Putin
would have never had the leverage to go
after Ukraine but now being where we are
it is our job to make sure that we
secure peace and Advance American
interests without sleepwalking into
World War III that is what I'm leading
us to do the answer is how have you
moved from a guy who illegally invades a
country a democratic sovereign country
you said the only way to stop this bully
Putin is to punch him in the nose but
when Ukraine in my view valiantly fight
for their territory and their people and
Putin still takes a load of their land
your answer to the bully is to now give
him what he's taken illegally
no that's not correct actually it's
going to be to require a major
concession from that bully so that we
don't ratchet this up to the next level
no no Peter Spears I think you're either
I mean and it's not your job to know
every aspect of everything I've said if
you're questioning on me on it I would
ask you to know what I've said countless
times I would actually require Putin to
exit his military alliance with China
that is the big demand and requirement
we will have for any deal of any kind
that russia-china military Alliance is
the single greatest threat to the west
and to the United States as we know it
Putin is in XI jinping's arms communist
China is fundamentally hostile to the
United States and I have a Clear Vision
for how to pull Russia apart from China
we will end the Ukraine war on terms
that leave Ukraine's sovereignty intact
I will note peers I'm skeptical that
that's even the path that Ukraine is on
right now so that's a win for Ukraine
but more importantly it's a winner it's
not a win for you crazy you know what if
you were president of the United States
yeah but giving a bully what he's taken
illegally is not to me strong leadership
is it
well Pierce I'm not giving anybody what
he's taken the fact of the matter is we
have to honor our covenants we had a
commitment to Ukraine in 1994 we've
fulfilled that commitment but James
Baker also made a commitment to
Gorbachev in 1990 on behalf of the U.S
saying that NATO would expand not one
inch past East Germany turns out NATO
has expanded far more after the fall of
the USSR than when the USSR activities
that we should be clear okay NATO should
not admit Ukraine to Nato okay but I
want to be really clear about this beers
I'm not letting Putin has his actions
are Craven I've said so but I don't
trust Putin I do trust him to follow his
self-interest
that causes him to exit we will I mean
many autocrats around the world or
bullies Putin is one of them but the
fact of the matter is you have to
actually do a deal that advances
everybody's self-interest okay require
Russia to exit its partnership with
China okay that's the key to the kingdom
to secure peace and keep us out of World
War III in fact we run out of time on
this interview but I you know I'd love
to do with it I I feel like I've
interviewed you a lot but for you know
five to ten minutes at a time I don't
think as you get better and better known
people want to know more about you as a
human being I would love to get the
chance to sit down with you and have a
proper one-on-one about who you are
where you've come from because I think
you are igniting this whole presidential
race in an exciting way I don't agree
with you about some of the stuff you're
saying not least Ukraine but I do love
the way that you're out there doing your
thing and I would love to get a chance
to get to know you better
I enjoy our exchanges it would be
bizarre if we agreed on everything right
so let's do that join us on the campaign
Trail I'm talking to you from our
campaign bus ride the bus with us we'll
spend a day together I'd enjoy that and
you can also see how some of the
audiences here in the US are responding
yeah I think it's it's really motivating
to me but it's it's quite something to
see so final question before I'll let
you go and I want a quick answer if you
were president of the United States and
you might be in a year or so time what's
the first thing you would do what's your
number one priority
Implement a 75 head count reduction in
the federal bureaucrat base and shut
down government agencies that should not
exist that's how you revive the
lifeblood of a constitutional republic
it's also how you grow the economy
that's what I'll start on on day one
you're a fascinating guy and your race
is exciting people good and bad and ugly
but that's the way it often is I look
forward to meeting with you properly
face to face and having a more in-depth
chat thank you very much
thank you peers I look forward to that
well let's open next the Pierce bag
we're waiting with baiting Brett to
Feast on these two meaty interviews with
the London mayor and the rising star of
the Republican party I'll talk to them
next
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
coming up on The Talk education
secretary Jillian Keegan is caught on
camera claiming she's doing an effing
good job despite School concrete crisis
hundreds of council staff are working
from the beach as there's a 10-fold
increase in staff logging on abroad and
as Prince Harry prepares to return to
the UK it's revealed his latest Netflix
series has flopped by failing to reach
the top 10 programs on that platform
that's all coming up at nine
thank you
welcome back to Facebook joined by
Esther crackhead talk TV contributor and
Associates of Daily Mirror Kevin McGraw
you've been waiting very patiently
watching these two big interviews Esther
Sadiq Khan yes he attracts equal amounts
of loathing and love he's obviously been
re-elected he probably will win again
judging by the candidate put up against
him what do you make of that interview I
was very surprised I went into that
interview wanting to throw eggs at him
over Euless I still kind of do but he
was very polished he was he seemed very
sincere and the thing is you can you can
understand his appeal I've often made
comparisons between him and Suella
Brotherman because I think they're two
terrible politicians but actually I
think he needs to do more interviews in
this style because it makes him seem
more genuine and more likable in ways
that swallow brother just isn't he's not
as unappealing and as repelling as she
is I mean I think Kevin with him that I
I having personally discovered that
pollution was really impacting my health
and doing something about it and it
working and it was cleaner air I I am
you know I'm pretty wedded to this idea
we get any better quality of air yeah
it's how he's doing it seems to be
divisive because it does seem to be the
poor elements of society in London that
are having to pay because they can't
afford to make the transition to the new
or expensive cars and that is the
problem is he's got to go over all the
poorest in London of course they use
public transport but it the fact is he's
doing something yeah and he is a
politician who's doing now charging is
crude so I'm normally hostile to it but
you can't carry on with dirty air in
London it is a very polluted one of the
things I found difficult to square with
that policy is because of the mot
emissions test that were updated in 2018
and will probably be updated in the next
couple of years you know you actually
could have realistically waited a couple
of years before you implemented I think
he has to I think you'll have to adapt
it but I do think I think his heart is
in the right place on it yeah and I
think that's what people that's why
probably the polls are divided because I
think people think what he's right about
is it it's like the Eco guys with the
throwing the paint around if they didn't
do that I'd be more supportive because I
remember the opposition he mentioned it
said he can't mentioned it it's a Euless
in the central London and then people
most people realize they don't pay it
yeah most cars are compliant yeah in out
of London most people are going to
realize their cars are compliant if
you've got a car that isn't compliant
you're gonna have to pay the charge it's
generally a diesel more than eight years
or a petrol over 16 years very few cars
let's talk quickly about Vivek ramaswamy
fascinating character fascinating I feel
like he talks in in like into internet
sound bites like he doesn't make any
sort of well he's a dynamic
entrepreneurial guy you know he's one of
those motivated types yeah he's
memorable he's like one of those
entrepreneur like sites you like Pages
you follow on Instagram being like Oh
yeah drink cold water in the morning to
get you going like that's what he is but
is he is he real or is this all just
show and no substance do you think I
would say oh sure no substance I think
he's glib uh look he's changed his
position on Ukraine he wouldn't admit
that he talks about the truth but he was
peddling uh 911 conspiracy theory he
didn't change his position he didn't
know what he was talking about because
he doesn't have the well he wanted to
give the bully a punch in the face but
now wants to give the bully what he took
and I don't yeah that's where those two
positions but he certainly he's
energized that race there's no question
about that yeah um guys I've got to
leave it there thank you for being
patient listening to those two
interviews we'll get you back and have a
longer chat about other things we've
missed in this summer but good to see
you both that's it for me it's good to
be back even if you're looking at me
spitting with rage it's good to see you
again and remember whatever you're up to
Keep It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
Trump yeah look at him fail about
working just cause their skin folk don't
mean they're kinfolks do you believe you
can win this war but it's making me cry
again I'm trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy letby will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS managers to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the concelli party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
thank you
[Music]